we don't have enough addresses to
represent every machine so what we can
do is we can kind of fake things out and
so that's where you get NAT Anthony NAT
is network address translation it's
allowing this bit of the network to stay
as it is using ipv4 even while we've got
too many computers connected to actually
fit the new ipv4 address with
this prefix here which always refers to
the first 16 bits 1 2 8 2 4 3 has been
handed out at the university not to you
so university knocking computers will
typically be I don't know if we have
other prefixes but certainly many of
them will be within that prefix let's
imagine that you've got you know the
university of knotting is sort of on
that side this line we could have lots
and lots and lots and lots of computers
behind it if we can translate the
addresses for each of these machines so
that they can fit within on 28.24 3 dot
something dot something we can sort of
pretend to the rest of the world that
this prefix contains enough addresses
for us well we've got lots of machines
behind that all kind of using and
reusing addresses within that space
and that was one of those things which
was kind of just dawn as a hack to make
things work because it was just
necessary and so there's lots of
idiosyncrasies in the ways of different
implementations of it work and it wasn't
sort of standardized in advance and then
there was a nice set of rules that we
could follow people just kind of made it
work and then retrospectively looked
anything on kind of what have we done
here we've got some data in our packet
and we've got a TCP header and we've got
an IP header what NAT does is it uses
some of the bits in the TCP header and
uses them essentially to extend the
address space for the IP addresses the
particular bits it uses what's called
the port numbers and in particular using
the source port very commonly the idea
with that is that when you're talking to
another application on internet so you
wear brands who's talking of a web
server for example it indicates that by
putting a value in the destination port
number and it's that which gets used by
the receiving computer to work out which
application should get given this data
so for web servers commonly that will be
port 80 and port 443 maybe one or two
others but those are the two standard
ones so port 80 is usually used for
carrying web traffic carrying HTTP it's
just the convention doesn't have to be
carry anything else you like on that but
that's the indicator that's used by the
receiving machine to say which
application gets this data and that's
the destination port now the source port
is used by the receiving machine to know
where to send the response back to but
it can be manipulated along the way
providing that manipulation can be kind
of undone
on the way back so there might be a
machine here of the kind of at the
gateway at the University of Nottingham
Network which is able to say okay we've
got far too many machines here to fit
inside this space we're gonna have to
map the address of let's say this
machine 10.0.0.0 - there know how to get
to 1 2 8 2 4 3 dot something and so we
need to convert this address here into
an address that fits inside there so
what we could do is we could set up a
little table and it could say ok 10.00
on this side this gateway machine here
is going to convert
that into one 28.24 3.20 dot 20 and
that's fine and that'll work but that
means we still only have this many slots
so what it could also do is it could say
okay well how about I also rewrite the
source port number as well
so that when it says source port 30 2621
I'm going to remap that to source port
16 and so what we've got here is we're
looking at taking all of this data and
remapping it into that and because each
machine here will typically not be using
the maximum possible number of
connections you end up with the ability
to fit more machines activity into the
same number of addresses this is called
multiplexing when you're taking more
things and picking them into a smaller
thing essentially so on the way out this
translation happens in that direction
then on the way back it has to be
translated back in the alliteration so
that something out here you know the
server that you were trying to get to
over here it's sending stuff back to 1
to a 2 4 3 20 20 destination port 16 and
then it's this gateway here is the only
thing in the world that knows that that
really maps to this particular machine
and that particular application on that
particular machine and so you've got
this translation that happens in one
direction and you have to undo the
translation in the other direction to be
able to get back to and that's what
makes this complex how does that equate
to say me sitting at home on my bra so
it's exactly the same process modulo the
particular details of how math is
working in a particular device but
basically it's the same process so
inside your home network for example if
you ever look at the IP addresses of any
of your devices you might see that
they'll often start with 10 there will
be 10.0 a lot something will 10.1 not
something or they'll start with 191 6 8
but something or in some cases they may
start with 172 dot something that's a
bit rarer and those addresses all those
sets of the dresses are in what's called
private addresses so you never see them
on the public internet they're only for
use behind one of these devices in a
private network and then it's you're a
Rooter that does the translation for you
each router in your home has
actually has a unique address it's not
being done by the ISP they're in this
translation well so what's happening is
you've got a Rooter sitting in your home
and that's connected by a cable to your
ISPs network there will be a public
address on this side of the cable and
then on this side inside your home
you've got all these private addresses
and then there's a public address here
and it's this Rooter here that's doing
this process for all of your private
addresses so your laptop your iPad your
phone whatever it is that you've got
inside your house all of their accesses
out to the network they're getting
translated so that your ISP which then
connects through to usually in many
urban bigger networks eventually you
know to somebody like Google or
something as far as your eyes P is
concerned they've been given a certain
amount certain number of addresses and
they're using those addresses to support
many people each of whom have many many
computers perhaps and so these layers of
translation are happening in order that
your data can get through to Google and
Google's responsible whoever it might be
Microsoft response can get back to you
all the while without having enough of
these IP addresses to cover every single
households use of all of these computers
so that translation is happening
everywhere it's allowing this bit of the
network to stay as it is using ipv4 even
while we've got too many computers
connected to actually fit with the new
idea for address space
and that makes them Network less robust
you've now ended up with sort of single
point so this guy here for example this
Reuter here is the only thing that knows
how to do this translation and so that
fails stop stop working it's more
complex to kind of set up backups and
things because they have to now share
all this information there's got to be
maintained there's gotta be maintained
in that place you've also got problems
to do with the complexity this
introduces so you can have situations
perhaps where your network might also be
doing this same process when it talks to
other networks because your networks not
being able to get enough addresses for
all the customers it's got and so you've
got this translation happening in
multiple places and it becomes difficult
then for somebody to debug what's going
on so things aren't working quite right
but you've got all these different
layers of translation it becomes quite
complex to see what's happening if you
believe this sort of strict picture
where you've got Ethernet at the bottom
you've got IP above that you've got TCP
above that you've got let's say HTTP
above that so this is the protocols of
the web users you believe that really
strictly there should be no cases where
information from down here is being used
directly to do things at this layer
there should be no cases where
information this layer is being used to
ready to do things at that layer these
abstractions should be maintained but in
practice they're not for a variety of
reasons many good engineering reasons in
some cases when you start doing things
like that another protocol might have
been relying on knowing the source
address for example when the source
address gets changed under its feet
without it knowing about it you end up
with a situation where somewhere in the
data in the packet you've got the source
address ten dot 0 dot 0 dot
in the header by the NAP machine that's
been changed to one two eight two four
three dot twenty twenty and suddenly
these things don't match anymore
so when you're trying to connect to it
another computer this is the addresses
use that's fine negating the right
computer but then when the software in
my computer tries to refer to the
address that the packet came from it
ends up having to use this address and
that's no longer the right address
and so that protocol is brittle in the
face of this kind of manipulation
because it's now not going to work quite
correctly so this was its particular
problem with Internet telephony you may
want to set up a connection between two
machines which are both in somebody's in
different people's houses behind this
kind of translation
the first machine tries to essentially
place a phone call to the second machine
what address should it use because it
can't know which of these $10 dresses or
one line two addresses it is because
that's translation is going to be
maintained by the nap box that's sitting
in the home gateway of that house I'm
reaching that house and so it doesn't
know what the translation is yet as
though it's got no way to refer to the
particular phone and wants to ring
inside that house as soon as then a
whole bunch of other protocols had to be
developed to try and allow that kind of
situation to be resolved where you
wanted to get essentially kind of have
those two machines rendezvous to
exchange information about what their
current private addresses are and what
the current public facing addresses are
according to the NAP process that's run
in front of them so that the guy making
the call can use the right public
address try and get the packets through
to the right place
in the network the protocols running
above which previously could assume that
if they looked at the IP at their source
IP address it really would be their
source IP address and everybody else
could reach that and so they could
always use that now they can't and that
assumption then breaks the way those
protocol for breaking that assumption
breaks those protocols each of these
different layers provides a different
set of abstractions it sort of builds on
the abstractions provided by whatever's
below it and it provides some
abstraction of the thing above it for
example if you look at an Ethernet
header essentially you've got a sequence
of stuff on there so you start out with
the destination address then you have a
source address and then depending on
precisely the version of Ethernet you're
running you have some information about
the protocol of what's coming next